I'll tell you what he can shoot the
basketball
and if you can shoot the basketball this
is where you have to be something to the
athleticism eros
ladies
[Applause]
better deepest worker in Seville the
cooker is killing over
so good you look at him he's such a good
passer you want to reward the big man
anytime he's put that effort out too
rough Austin Rivers pumps up a three
[Applause]
really is just too good and he passes
well why don't you you never know if
that's a floater close doesn't matter
matter in this game I mean that's very
good
I don't see a way in which he is not
wearing a rocket uniform and playing
37-0
the defensive lives within he has now
create an advantage in two feet in the
paint and getting a wide open three desk
that's good office you see
[Applause]
we'll have the lead at the break the
question will be by how much
[Applause]
Magruder is a savvy player how do you
defend that well I mean my thing is this
how many times do you see people block
three points up shots
[Applause]
I agree I think I think the Lakers no
obviously would be formidable I think
them there is right there
[Applause]
[Music]
it's great that no monster the last
couple years with equipment yes he has
see this wall of crazy we can't let him
get behind
he's just he's just too smart is too
brilliant you see they tried to pick him
up at full court he gets you on his hip
right there and he makes you stay right
there and then your instincts kick over
and try to slap down his buildable court
he gets you on his hip right there and
he makes you stay right there and then
your instincts kick over rockets in
black Russell Westbrook hardly got the
three off but it's good for James Harden
way getting it going here's an N and
Opie I'm gonna reach harden I should say
Westbrook knocked it loose Westbrook
finds capela go to the rim and one
first-team all-nba player is he if he
can mesh yeah but sometimes it doesn't
have to do with ability sometimes
there's other things involved do don't
look low bye again
Wow art mid sees it forms Patrick McCall
comes back on the floor
Westbrook finds capela and those two
have got a little early chemistry no
stranger to that his father was in the
arm and he lived in Frankfort as a shot
there's harden it's the runner game
pardon
James Harden averaged over 40 points a
game over a 40 game scan last year
between December and March and there he
finds capella and one James Harden with
the assist capella will go to the line
with a chance at a three-point front
with the basketball but then getting the
ball within the flow of the offense and
receiving the time Wow he put it up in
the Europe the last couple of years and
and he signed a contract that the
Raptors and that was impressive pass
there to McLemore for the finish for
Houston to the game tied at 38 Tokyo
fans anticipating to clear out hard
step-back Kansa 321 for James Harden
Oh G on an Obi twisting through
rebounded by the Rockets westbrook
pushing accelerating and finishing what
a great example of what he can't break
and it's heat up they need to stay
attached better this hollis-jefferson
I'm sorry harden the step-back three and
it's good for James Harden
[Applause]
turn it out by see how come and then
expand please from team Gordon to three
and it's good for Eric Gordon Capello is
really influenced to harden to Westbrook
to bring it out Westbrook attacking Oh
with a reverse Russell Westbrook
dazzling am in Tokyo
[Music]
give it a hardened late the shot clock
hardened pawn him I'll fade away is good
32 for hardened he's used to having it
from the get-go I wouldn't be surprised
if they give it to him and as we see the
two-man game they're a capella given to
James Hart human to Westbrook and let
apart in the spot up you can see the
defense that big nerds is trying to
employ this year Westbrook up top for
capella his minutes it will certainly be
monitored here for the preseason is hard
and lifting it up again for capella
harden it's going back on the call for
three and he drains it let's do the
dance but if you
Westbrook drives to a double-teaming
dumps it off for Tyson Chandler as few
minutes but the Rockets in front here in
Tokyo VanFleet harden finding the open
man it's PJ Tucker and fleet way off
with the three not sure why he shot that
but it looks is nonetheless James Harden
plus the foul
seven seconds to go two-point Raptor
lead here's Westbrook right through the
lane to the cup and we're tied again
fries to see him exit soon as well just
get a couple more trips up and down
Westbrook putting on the moves and
finishing with the foul kind of loves
the definitive sleep you can see how the
help from the corner is ready to come
when some of the Rockets top players
well to the average fan it might not
mean much but if you're one of these
family members as Russell gets all the
way to the cup that might be how he
leaves his mark on this game off the
back of the iron shot it too hard look
at how strike it down
[ __ ] it's pretty good at that and harden
steps it right to the bucket and he went
through a little contact there
that stops the Houston rod look at
Westbrook he just put it in superstar
here therefore elevating changed his
shot here's our D in the open court
people basket how did he get that shot
up there and there's Murray again
alley-oop inside yep back more
he's kind of been under the radar in
Sacramento the last few years but he's
very good polite I can take a look at
the great pass James Horton over the top
to bend backwards and lanes in here to
catch it and throw it down great path
[Music]
harden steps back and fires balls down
hits it anywhere
well defended to let her finish that
hairs hard to stop him and shooting it
was run a walk with wins but I don't
know if that's good enough to get in
hardened from the front bro
somebody had left their seat just a few
years ago I thought I've lost a lot of
viewers on the Johnny Cash spacing not
good there's no housing harden same spot
other than the i-formation and hardness
2 maybe 3 exactly what happened Martin
into the paint and lava and water their
rockets beat the Spurs and Alba Murphy
and that great game against George
Gordon
[Applause]
and that is second only to the New
Orleans pelicans Bell's averaging 128 a
game of the preseason
it's Westbrook splashing home is triple
enough here comes respite
but Sefolosha finds the runaway reshef
elosha and a quick timeout came in the
preseason
makes those were off the chart numbers
better than their record-setting drink
with members of the year ago is with
their player so they understand exactly
the types of shots they want to take the
trail points for Dragon three assists
already for bamboo they're strong
passing this is the first time they need
have given up more than eight threes and
again in appreciation the rock attempts
hit none fighting on the on the pull
back his hand as straight out boy barely
touches him on the elbow there but
you're going to see hard to get that a
32 blue and that's because of this right
here what we're saying they isolate
marked or one-on-one let him create
they're not kiddin and they're gonna
shoot even more threes this year was
same shoot but they're averaging 57 in
the preseason
mark finishes in traffic was a good job
making himself available to the guards
with quick hands and finishes draws the
foul on out of I owe more to have to go
Mathur their party and there's another
three for James Harden to Azzam 33
points all teams say the same thing
you're the crew see we gotta clean up
our two daughters another three for
James Harden is this incredible 39
points he's still working James Harden
NBA scoring leader for a reason seven
field goal attempts James Hart is still
working 46 points for him what's up you
guys this Taylor Brooks with bleacher
report make sure that you subscribe for
some more video content